depuis bientôt deux mois les gilet jaune
de la charité sur loire se relaient sur
ce campement
ici la lettre d' emmanuel macron est
décortiqué depuis hier soir mais les
propos du président ne convainquent pas
ceux qui travaillent financent les
pensions des retraités
alors pourquoi des retraités ont des
taxes sur leur bulletin de pension si
c'est un type ont tâché de sagesse s'il
s'aperçoit qui s'est trompé il n'y a pas
de honte à dire je me suis trompé je
révise maccoppi là où il ya un an tu
sais quand on persiste dans l'erreur
sachant qu'on est dans l'erreur et
consacre uste dans l'événement aux
allant dans son courrier le chef de
l'état rappelle sa fidélité à son projet
ses grandes orientations à la veille du
grand débat national les mots dérange et
laisse l'impression d'une
incompréhension
il ya deux choses l isf et puis il ya le
pouvoir d'achat qu'étaient les deux
grandes revendications des aînés à ces
deux choses a hélas pas envie de
découvrir détricoter la chose la
providence better donc bon on va faire
avec toute façon on n'a pas le choix il
a décidé comme ça on va faire avec
on va pas non plus rester toute l'année
dehors il faut vraiment qu'ils se
bougent pour nous et nous trouver des
solutions à toutes ces taxes qui ne
servent à rien j'espère que ça va faire
bouger les gens qui n'hésiteront pas
remplir décalé de réans avec plus qu'ils
ont sur le coeur et puis toutes leurs
espérances
en espérant qu'elle aboutit 100 km
pourtant ici les manifestants ne sont
pas opposés au débat
la semaine dernière déjà une réunion
publique a eu lieu en présence de la
députée depuis le début on ne débat pas
pour débattre on débat pour donner des
solutions
voilà on ne fait pas que critiquer mais
on veut agir à la charité-sur-loire à la
lettre du président les gilet jaune de
la charité compte maintenant répondre
par un autre courrier une invitation à
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires pour venir discuter de la
ruralité